salut motte vous me connaissez bonjour
je m'appelle baptiste on m'a dit qu'est
ce que tu fais et oui c'est moi j'étais
pas mal non et
ça c'est ma mère mettez pas la bâtisse
mais si je traînais
il ya dix est en train de faire brûler
dans sa chambre et alors
[Musique]
mais savamment machiste qu'est ce que tu
fais
mais
c'est un truc
[Musique]
dans cette vidéo je m'amuse à faire
brûler
duquel la dent dans une pinte en est un
pourquoi ça c'est une bonne question
parce que je n'ai aucune des soins
moment j'en avais vraiment aucune et je
sais que pour la vidéo je me suis dit
tiens ça bêtement si on montrait ça aux
gens
[Musique]
tout et pas dans son état normal non ça
s'est passé le lundi et je commence
c'est les cours à cette heure du coup je
me lever à 4 heures et je devais prendre
du coup le train à son coeur sauf que ce
matin là je savais pas de j'avais patron
du coup je suis rentré chez moi je suis
j'ai dormi jusqu'à à peu près 18 heures
c'est à ce moment là que je me suis dit
que fallait vraiment que le torne parce
que j'en ai un je me lever à 4 heures du
coup j'ai décidé de prendre deux de
somnifères et pendant ce temps là je me
suis je prendre ma douche et c'est à ce
moment là que les somnifères ont
commencé à faire effet et danser
somnifères qui sont de niveau 3 et il ya
beaucoup d'effets secondaires et après
c'est devenu un peu flou dans les
souvenirs je me souviens
juste avoir mis du pétrole dans la tasse
indiqué l'ars et j'ai fait feu je me
suis amusé à peu près 30 minutes juste
avant de lancer le live
non
dix reprises le lendemain tu travailles
tu dis quoi lendemain j'ai aucun
souvenir de la veille ni de ce qui s'est
passé je vais je en cours normalement
personne n'en parle et le matin j'arrive
mon meilleur ami me dit ça fait quoi
hier soir et et je sais de quoi tu
parles du coup il montre la vidéo je
fais
quoi et du coup ça fait une énorme barre
on rigole et où pendant toute la journée
on sape des bars dessus et on se dit on
va essayer
on va retirer la vidéo quand elle
attendra un million et du coup c'est ce
qu'on a fait
[Musique]
mais à
meteb à une bâtisse mais qu'est ce que
tu fais merci je suis honnête moi je
m'en fous de ce que les gens y pensent
en général chez moi même et enfin je
veux dire ça va pas changer la
perception ou quoi que ce soit des
droits de quoi essayer de faire des
choses roche ou non pas dans ta chambre
non parce que c'est ma maison alors je
fais avec la bande et ryad gens qui la
place à des jeux fra vers précaution
moi ça me fait rire parce que c'est vrai
que c'est drôle en général les gens il
dit ils m'envoient des messages de
remerciements et il faut remercier de
m'avoir fait rire ce jour là est tout
l'enjeu n'était pas bien et tout et tu
m'a vraiment redonné le sourire du coup
c'est ça qui qui qui me fait plaisir
redonner le sourire aux gens c'est très
important mardi à l'eau ça marche oui
ouais ok jours bonjour vous aussi vous
en rigoler encore aujourd'hui
oui j'en rigole depuis seulement
quelques années un et pendant mois un an
j'ai déprimé
comme c'était pas possible j'avais peur
qui sait qu'on reconnaisse à l'école et
qui se passe qui se fasse virer quoi
voilà c'est
[Musique]
important quand même hein on pense
toujours à l'avenir de ses enfants sur
le moment où vous dites quoi mais je me
demandais je me demandais ce qu'il c'est
bon j'ai vu faire du feu mais je savais
pas du tout qu'il était en live sur
facebook c'est son frère qui nous a
informés je me demandais ce qui ça je
pensais qu'ils allaient pris des
stupéfiants je savais pas que j'étais
vraiment abasourdi quoi
j'avais surtout peur qui met le feu à la
mise
aujourd'hui c'est plutôt de la
bienveillance qui est autour de cette
vidéo oui bien sûr gâtechien
ça n'est pas de problème
on est adulte et quand même bâtisse
l'état du tout maintenant donc on voit
les choses autrement cinq ans après tu
deviens quoi qui est baptiste alors
actuellement j'ai 26 ans je travaille en
restauration et je suis aussi la faute
aux jeux six activistes dans le milieu
animal la défense de l'environnement les
messages à faire passer dans son
histoire aimez vous les uns les autres
surtout arrêter de juger les gens sans
les connaître c'est assez important